***
Sie fahren gerade über den Atlantik.
7 Tage nach New York, ohne Umwege.
Da empfangen sie eine Nachricht
von einem lang vermissten Schiff.
Sie finden es,
aber alles ist anders als erwartet.
Wo sind wir?
Keiner weiß, was passiert ist.
Nicht mal der Kapitän selbst.
Hallo,
mein Name ist Andreas Pietschmann.
Willkommen
bei "Science vs. Fiction".
*Musik*
Hallo, Jack Pop hier!
"1899" ist die neue,
heiß erwartete Netflix-Serie
aus der Feder
der Mystery-Profis von "Dark".
Auch hier dürfen wir wieder
viele außergewöhnliche Phänomene
und krasse Wendungen erwarten.
Aber wir wollen euch nicht
den Mystery-Spaß vermiesen.
Darum konzentrieren wir uns
auf die Trailer.
Und fragen ganz wissenschaftlich:
Was könnte tatsächlich passieren
mit einem verschollenen Schiff?
Nichts ergibt Sinn.
Das mache ich gemeinsam mit jemandem,
für den Schiffe das 2. Zuhause sind:
Meeresbiologe und Forschungstaucher
Uli Kunz.
Zum wissenschaftlichen Spekulieren
brauchen aber eine Grundlage.
Darum schauen wir mal in die Trailer,
was mit dem Schiff
eigentlich passiert.
Auch dafür haben wir uns Expertise
mit ins Boot geholt.
Nämlich Sebastian von "Filmstarts".
Die Frage, die sich zuerst stellt,
ist folgende:
Hi, Jack.
Zu Beginn der Serie erfahren wir,
dass das Schiff "Prometheus"
schon seit 4 Monaten vermisst wird.
Keiner glaubt daran,
sie je wiederzufinden.
Das ändert sich,
als man ein vermeintliches Signal
der "Prometheus" empfängt.
Und nach einem Kurswechsel
wirklich auf das Schiff stößt.
Von da an passieren
immer mehr merkwürdige Dinge.
Z.B. spielen alle Kompasse
plötzlich verrückt.
Gut möglich, dass die "Prometheus"
deshalb vom Kurs abgekommen ist.
Inwiefern das aber
wissenschaftlich möglich ist,
dürft ihr gern klären.
Vielleicht hat der Kapitän also
einfach die Orientierung verloren.
Denn dass Kompasse verrückt spielen,
kennen wir aus einigen Mythen.
V.a. wenn es
ums Bermuda-Dreieck geht.
Auch wenn das Serien-Poster
genauso dreieckig anmutet,
sind wir geografisch betrachtet
in "1899" weit weg vom Bermuda.
Trotzdem können wir
eine Sache mitnehmen.
Denn die Wetter-
und Ozeanografie-Behörde der USA
hat mittlerweile bestätigt,
dass es in der Bermuda-Region
zu Kompass-Anomalien kommt.
Eine Theorie dazu besagt,
dass es an einem bestimmten Gestein
im Meeresboden liegt.
Nämlich Magnetit.
Das ist ein natürlich vorkommendes
Eisenerz.
Und das ist stark magnetisch.
Kommt das in die Nähe eines Kompass,
richtet er sich danach aus
und kann verrückt spielen.
Warum sollte man es sonst
nicht gefunden haben?
Magnetit findet man z.B.
in erkalteter Lava.
Davon gibt es
unter den Bermuda-Inseln jede Menge.
Aber natürlich auch an vielen
anderen Stellen im Meeresboden.
Dort ist Uli Kunz oft unterwegs.
Er macht regelmäßig
Expeditions-Tauchgänge.
Mal unterm arktischen Eis,
mal in Begleitung von Orkas.
Gerade ist er
in Saudi-Arabien unterwegs.
Um eine neue Folge von "Terra X"
zu moderieren.
Darum haben wir
per Zoom mit ihm gesprochen.
Uli hat mir erzählt, dass man
vulkanisches Gestein samt Magnetit
entlang der Route der "Prometheus"
finden kann.
Nämlich im Nordatlantik und dort
v.a. am Mittelatlantischen Rücken.
Eine durchgehende Kette
von Vulkanen.
Da kommt
flüssiges Gestein nach oben.
Und presst diese beiden Regionen
rechts und links voneinander weg.
Dieses Gebirge
kann mehrere 1.000 m hoch sein.
Man sieht es nur nicht.
Es ist die längste Gebirgskette
auf der Erde.
Aber sie ist immer
unter mehreren Kilometern Wasser.
Außer man geht z.B. nach Island.
Und steigt da auf die Spitze
dieses Mittelatlantischen Rückens.
Da besteht die Chance,
viele Vulkane zu sehen.
Also viel vulkanisches Gestein
am Mittelatlantischen Rücken.
Und das Schiff hat den auf der Fahrt
auch wirklich überquert.
Die Frage ist also vielmehr:
Reicht der Magnetismus
im Meeresboden aus,
um den Kompass zu beeinflussen?
Es gibt auf der Erde
Kompass- bzw. Magnet-Anomalien,
die entstehen,
wenn z.B. riesige Erzlagerstätten
im Boden vergraben sind.
Da gibt es
ein paar Beispiele auf der Erde.
Aber der Mittelatlantische Rücken
gehört nicht dazu.
Da entsteht neues Gestein,
was dann wieder magnetisiert wird.
Im Entstehungsprozess.
Aber ich gehe nicht davon aus,
dass das
riesige Erzlagerstätten sind.
Die eine enorme Kompass-Anomalie
verursachen,
wie man das z.B. an so einer
großen Erzlagerstätte findet.
Schade, das wäre
eine einfache Lösung gewesen.
Wir halten fest:
Der Magnetismus ist zu schwach,
als dass ein Kompass verrückt spielt.
Du stellst nicht
die richtigen Fragen.
Ich habe noch eine Idee,
wie die "Prometheus"
vom Kurs abgekommen sein könnte.
Davon konnte der Kapitän
noch nichts wissen.
Denn das Phänomen
wurde erst in den letzten 25 Jahren
richtig erforscht.
Monsterwellen!
Die "Prometheus"
scheint auf den 1. Blick
ganz gut auszusehen.
Ein bisschen verrostet,
aber nach 4 Monaten auf dem Wasser
ist das nicht verwunderlich.
Allerdings sind einige Fenster
auf der Kommandobrücke kaputt.
Und drinnen
ist es ziemlich chaotisch.
Die Betten und Stühle,
alles hängt kreuz und quer.
Alles ist dreckig
und teilweise ziemlich schimmelig.
Also gut möglich,
dass da Wasser eingedrungen ist.
Könnte also sein,
dass das Schiff getroffen wurde.
Aber schauen wir mal,
was Monsterwellen eigentlich sind.
Die definieren sich
nicht nur über ihre Höhe,
sondern über ihre Höhe im Vergleich
zu den Wellen um sie herum.
Eine Monsterwelle
muss mind. 2-mal höher sein
als die Wellen um sie herum.
Bei einem Seegang, wo alle Wellen
durchschnittlich 2 m hoch sind,
wäre schon eine Welle mit 5 m Höhe
eine Monsterwelle.
Aber es gibt auch
richtig fette Dinger
mit 20, 25 oder 30 m Höhe.
Krass finde ich, dass man
erst seit 1995 daran forscht.
Damals krachte eine Welle
von 26 m Höhe
auf die Draupner-Ölbohrplattform
in der Nordsee.
Eine Welle so hoch
wie das Brandenburger Tor.
Das war der offizielle Beweis.
Bis dahin hatte man geglaubt,
dass Wellen über 15 m Höhe
physikalisch nicht möglich seien.
Entsprechend
wurden die Schiffe gebaut.
Heiliger Geist,
bewahre uns vor dem Bösen
und all der Falschheit dieser Welt.
Heute ist also unstrittig,
dass es sie gibt.
Aber ob es sie dort gibt,
wo die "Prometheus" ist,
im Nordatlantik,
das habe ich Uli Kunz gefragt.
In der Nordsee
sprechen wir von Wind gegen Strom.
Der Wind treibt die Wellen
in die eine Richtung.
Aber die Strömung
will die Oberfläche
in eine andere Richtung bringen.
Wenn dann eine Welle kommt,
wird der Fuß
von der Strömung weggerissen.
Die Welle
baut sich viel schneller auf.
Und wird viel steiler.
Dadurch kommt es
zu kleinen, kurzen Wellen
die sich
sehr schnell aufbauen können.
Zu sog. Freak Waves
oder Monsterwellen.
Starke Strömungen
gibt es auch im Nordatlantik.
Z.B. den Golfstrom.
Der könnte
eine Monsterwelle verursachen.
Ich habe
die Koordinaten der "Prometheus"
mal bei Google Earth eingegeben.
Es könnte Strömungsregion sein.
Und wir hätten eine super Erklärung.
Aber es gibt ein Problem.
In der Serie wird gesagt,
die "Prometheus"
hätte mit der Strömung
weiter nach Norden treiben müssen.
Gefunden wird sie aber
viel weiter südlich.
Was wenn Strömungen
nichts damit zu tun haben?
Können Monsterwellen
auch anders entstehen?
Im Endeffekt gibt es
mehrere Erklärungsmöglichkeiten.
Das eine ist,
dass mehrere Wellen sich überlagern.
Die bauen sich sozusagen
übereinander auf.
Das sind mehrere Wellen.
Eine ist vielleicht etwas schneller
als die andere.
Dann überholt die eine
die andere Welle
und baut sich
mit der kleineren Welle
zu einer noch höheren Welle auf.
Durch Radarmessungen
der Meeresoberfläche
hat man mittlerweile herausgefunden,
dass die viel häufiger auftreten
als uns das lieb sein kann.
Die "Prometheus"
hätte also von einer Monsterwelle
getroffen werden können.
Und zwar überall
entlang ihres Kurses.
Aber würde das Schiff
dann so aussehen,
wie Sebastian es beschrieben hat?
Wir fragen wieder Uli Kunz.
Ich habe früher auf
einem Kreuzfahrtschiff gearbeitet,
in der Antarktis.
Ich war zum Glück nicht an Bord,
als das Schiff getroffen wurde
von einer Monsterwelle.
In der Antarktis können auch
sehr starke Stürme auftreten.
Und manchmal auch
eine große Strömung.
Das Schiff wurde schwer beschädigt.
Die Brücke wurde zerstört.
Das Wasser hat eine Scheibe
aus der Brücke rausgedrückt.
Hinter dem Fenster
stand der Kapitän,
der wurde ohnmächtig geschlagen.
Die Brücke stand binnen Sekunden
meterhoch unter Wasser.
Die Elektronik ist ausgefallen.
Man kann sich also vorstellen,
dass ein Schiff in einem Sturm
ganz schnell in Seenot geraten kann,
wenn dann noch
lebenswichtige Systeme ausfallen.
Auf die Erfahrung hätte ich auch
gut und gern verzichtet.
Aber es erklärt, warum es
auf dem Schiff so chaotisch war.
Jetzt denkt ihr vielleicht:
Wenn so ein Schiff
heutzutage getroffen wird,
und dann schon so aussieht,
obwohl es viel massiver ist,
hätte es ein Schiff 1899
doch sicher komplett zerlegt.
Und nicht nur
ein paar Tische umgeschmissen.
Dachte ich auch erst.
Aber schaut euch mal das an.
Das ist die "Oceanic".
Die war wie die "Prometheus"
1899 mit Migrant*innen an Bord
über den Atlantik
Richtung USA unterwegs.
Bei einer ihrer Überfahrten
wurde sie mitten auf dem Nordatlantik
von einer Monsterwelle getroffen.
Zumindest glaubt man das heute.
Die Decks wurden komplett
vom Wasser überrollt.
Die Glasfront an der Brücke
wurde eingeschlagen.
Und es wurden auch
ein paar Personen verletzt.
Aber dem Schiff an sich
ist nichts weiter passiert.
Jetzt passiert das Gleiche hier.
Apropos verletzte Passagiere:
Eine Frage ist noch offen.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Wir wissen
durch einen Zeitungsartikel,
dass auf der "Prometheus"
mal über 1.400 Passagiere
und 550 Besatzungsmitglieder
an Bord waren.
Ansonsten fehlt aber
jede Spur von denen.
Und das Schiff
sieht auch nicht gerade so aus,
als hätte hier
noch großartig jemand gelebt.
Alles verlassen, ohne Erklärung?
Aber so ungewöhnlich ist das nicht.
Es gibt immer wieder Schiffe,
die menschenleer
einfach so im Meer rumtreiben.
Das bekannteste Beispiel
ist die "Mary Celeste".
Die trieb 1872 zwischen Portugal
und den Azoren umher.
Man glaubt,
dass das Verschwinden der Crew
mit der Ladung des Schiffes
zusammenhängt.
Sie hatte Fässer
mit Rohalkohol an Bord.
Da ist wahrscheinlich
Ethanol-Dampf ausgetreten.
Der zwang die Crew,
das Schiffes zu verlassen.
Gleiches Spiel
beim britischen Tanker "Diala".
Auch hier musste die Crew
das Schiff verlassen.
Weil es im 2. Weltkrieg
von einem deutschen U-Boot
torpediert wurde.
Es ist aber nicht direkt gesunken,
sondern noch eine Weile
umhergetrieben.
Auch heute gibt es sowas noch.
2008 ist ein
taiwanesisches Fischereischiff
komplett ohne Besatzung
im Pazifik aufgetaucht.
Vor der Küste
vom Inselstaat Kiribati.
Anscheinend ist ein Brand
an Deck ausgebrochen.
Es wurde aber nie
ein Notruf abgesetzt.
Wenn wir mal zusammenfassen,
was wir besprochen haben,
stelle ich mir die wissenschaftliche
Story von "1899" etwa so vor:
Die "Prometheus" beginnt ihre Fahrt
von Europa Richtung USA
über den Atlantik.
Alles ist gut.
Bis sie nahe des Golfstroms
in einen Sturm gerät.
Die Strömung drückt die Wassermassen
Richtung Nordosten.
Aber die Wellen
bewegen sich Richtung Südwesten.
Das Schiff
beginnt immer mehr zu schwanken.
Die Strömung schiebt die Wellen
immer mehr zusammen.
Dabei werden sie
immer höher und steiler.
Plötzlich baut sich eine Monsterwelle
vor dem Schiff auf
und überrollt einfach alles.
Weder der Kapitän noch die Besatzung
haben eine Chance,
etwas zu unternehmen.
Die Scheiben der Brücke
sind eingeschlagen,
Passagiere sind verletzt,
der Kapitän ist bewusstlos
und die ganze Elektrik
ist ausgefallen.
Wenig später bemerkt die Besatzung
ein Leck am Schiffrumpf.
Alle Passagiere werden schnell
in Rettungsbooten evakuiert.
Das Schiff sinkt aber nicht,
wie man angenommen hatte.
Sondern treibt dann,
wie der britische Tanker,
noch wochenlang als Geisterschiff
auf offenem Meer umher.
Bei allen Science-Erklärungen,
die wir gegeben haben:
Eine Mystery-Serie
will v.a. Mystery sein.
D.h., es wird
zu verrückten Wendungen kommen
und zu Phänomenen,
die wir gar nicht besprochen haben.
Aber das macht für mich
den Reiz an "1899" aus.
Sehr schön fand ich,
dass ich die 2 Macher,
Jantje Friese und Baran bo Odar
sprechen konnte.
Die haben mir erklärt,
wie man als Mystery-Profi
so eine Serie schaut.
Und was wir zu erwarten haben.
Auf jeden Fall wieder
ein krasses Puzzle-Spiel.
Wo man gut aufpassen muss,
gerne mit Stift und Block.
Muss man nicht, aber wer Lust hat,
kann das gerne tun.
Wichtig ist,
auf die Details zu achten.
Und man kann sich überlegen,
mit welchen wissenschaftlichen
Konzepten das zusammenhängt.
In Folge 7 wird offenbart,
worum es tatsächlich geht.
Es ist also ein bisschen
Informationen sammeln
und gucken, ob man die Antwort
vor Folge 7 gefunden hat.
Das komplette Interview haben wir
als Zusatz-Content hochgeladen.
Den Link findet ihr in der Info-Box.
Dort gibt es auch die Links
zu Uli Kunz
und zu Sebastian von "Filmstarts".
Vielen Dank an die beiden
für ihre Expertise.
Ich sage: Viel Spaß bei "1899".
Ich hoffe,
wir sehen uns in 2 Wochen wieder.
Bis dahin, tschau.
Wie, du hast den Kanal
noch nicht abonniert?
Bo-jemine!
Mach das doch noch.
Und vergiss dabei nicht,
die Glocke zu drücken.
(lacht) Ist das laut!
Copyright MDR 2022